saleh
week-end
c'est encore notre séjour à la mer si
oui et vous êtes contents de revenir
oui
lego puis travailler
free vous aimeriez repartir ce retour
c'était le 22 mars à bord de 200 petits
bordelais venait à ces trois semaines à
la neige à gourette
ils ont rapporté l' excellent souvenir
de belles images gravées en leur mémoire
paris le 2 mars il y était resté ainsi
jusqu'au 22 monsieur chaban delmas ce
début de l'année avec nos soeurs les
classes de sa ville qui bénéficieraient
de cette scolarité exceptionnelle en
sang sont dans un avion par les huit
classes avaient été désignés classe de
bars en place deux filles classes mixtes
ce point la veille pour les jeunes
parents d'importance la participation
financière demandée aux parents étaient
minimes
de ce côté là non plus aucun problème
majeur n'avait été évoqué alors les
enfants tu y es tu dans toute liberté
ont pu travailler soit le matin soit
l'après-midi ce qui est soit
l'après-midi soit le matin les heures de
la journée trop courts avait été
équitablement partagés et ils ont fait
nous livrer ce spectacle apaisant d'une
jeunesse heureuse
à titre d'exemple ce sont ses souvenirs
que nous allons faire ressurgir pour
notre plaisir et nous l'espérons aussi
pour le l'air et pour le vôtre
derrière voilà
alessi allez-vous nom et un vide un
lignage il faut épaules quand on fonde
alors on va poser pour la photo et
donnez moi voilà à deux états olivier
vous y êtes chef pour la photo tél
par quoi cette avalanche peut-elle être
provoqué par don par le bruit je ne
crois pas qu'il s'agisse du bruit dans
la lecture par la fonte des neiges le
soleil le soleil mais encore quels
effets du soleil
quels effets du soleil sinon celui qui
fut son ami donc quels effets du soleil
la chaleur près à toi large dos je n'ai
pas de crainte comme je mens pour une
mise à jour ni trop laides demande à mon
gré et pardonne à ses études
je souffre de voir mes chers pas si la
cie méticuleux et a même atteint 6
pouces ou en réalité il marche très bien
je suis un passionné mais je suis
impatient et bien nous rappeler très
bien compte des possibilités
donc nous allons faire la correction du
calcul marie-véronique les tableaux
corinne clergé tuvalu lié n'est pas
contre et 113 / raymond felton
tous barbus et jarville 2 chiffres j'ai
deux chiffres aux diviseurs j'en prends
le dividende jeudi en 62 communes x 78
ça se veut pas alors je prends tu
trouves archives jeudi en 344 commeinhes
x 98 3 x 8 24 24 août et xen 4-0 et je
retiens deux trois fois neuf 27 27 et du
30 au désir de maintenir l'aide mais
peut-être un quart 5 et j'avais su un
julian 16 ans 1 comme une fois 98
montréal compte comme une fois 9 gc
cette fois sa famille car entendre des
41 des jours diane 47.9 45 45 4 49 49 50
m est tout ému il a quitté sa chair sur
cette famille le monde sera mieux
mourir à jamais et nous ont dit qu'ils
allaient nous offrons ces quelques jeux
pour rire ou bien aux émetteurs